[Music]
recently our staff was hit with the flu
ellen has tested positive for covid the
62 year old made the announcement
herself today on instagram
saying she's feeling fine and following
all proper cdc
guidelines and anyone who has been in
close contact with me
has been notified how exactly ellen
contracted the virus is a mystery but
her live audience returned to her show
six weeks ago
these were her most recent guests please
welcome leslie odom jr
my friend diane keaton brian cranston a
source tells e.t
ellen has been trying to be as careful
as possible when filming
other than being with porsha she was
spending time in montecito with a few
friends
while wearing mass and distance the
truth is i love doing the show the truth
is i i get to
walk out here to a bunch of people that
have traveled from very far away
to sit in those seats because they like
me
and so there's a bunch of love in this
room we're told ellen is now
quarantined at home feeling okay and
focused on getting better
11 of her signature 12 days of giveaways
have
aired so far but starting today the show
will be in repeats until january
also today i just wanted to come on and
let you know that i just tested positive
for
covid19 the talks carry anna naba
sharing the news from her sick bed
the rest of the ladies have tested
negative so far and taped their last new
show of the year
today i have a fever and
bad cough i'm following all the
protocols and
we have so many protocols in place
and even then i caught it so just
friendly reminder to stay vigilant and
take care of yourself and wear your
masks please and wash your hands a lot
and just be extra extra careful because
you don't want this